devra-t-on retarder l'âge de départ à la
retraite à cause des dettes liées à la
crise ça c'est la grosse question la
crise se traduit comme vous savez par
une forte hausse du taux de chômage qui
frappe surtout les jeunes
et naturellement retarder l'âge de
départ à la retraite
ça voudrait dire que les seniors restent
plus longtemps dans les entreprises donc
que les jeunes ne vont pas trouver leur
place et donc ça aggraverait encore la
situation du du marché du travail et des
difficultés pour les jeunes par ailleurs
à plus long terme bien sûr il faut se
poser une question avec un grand nombre
de paramètres d'un côté la croissance
l'emploi et de l'autre aussi la
contrainte écologique qui fait que
naturellement on va pas avoir une
croissance fabuleuse dans les décennies
les années et les décennies à venir
il faut réfléchir planifier la situation
je pense que la meilleure situation
c'est le partage du travail
le partage des revenus il faut accepter
de limiter notre empreinte écologique
donc obligatoirement un peu notre
consommation matérielle est donc cette
réduction se partage du temps de travail
ça signifie aussi que c'est pas la peine
de forcer les gens à
aller au delà de 62 ans il vaut mieux
partager le temps de travail partagé les
revenus
[Musique]